difficile pour les hôpitaux du pays de
faire face à l'afflux de patients depuis
le début de l'épidémie de kovy de 19 en
france
alors pour tenter de rassurer la
population d'informer parfois de
pratiquer le fameux test des centres
qu'ovide ouvre un peu partout sur le
territoire
nos équipes sont allées dans l'un
d'entre eux dans le var reportage
d'isabelle ferrières et walid bennani
une école maternelle transformés en
centres de consultation à la
seyne-sur-mer une trentaine de patients
choisissent chaque jour cet
établissement pour se rassurer et
parfois se faire dépister
sourira est venu accompagner son père
fatigué ces derniers jours et qui se
plaint de courbatures les deux sont dans
un premier temps pris en charge par une
infirmière
toutes les questions sont bons à poser
en cette période d'épidémie
quand est-ce qu'ils ont eu de la fièvre
des frissons découvert des courbatures
de la toux s'ils ont des nausées de la
diarrhée
ils ont été s'ils ont mal aux ventes
s'ils ont des douleurs thoraciques s'ils
ont perdu le goût s'ils ont perdu
l'odorat
on leur demande s'ils ont des centres
des antécédents cardiaques respiratoires
s'ils ont du diabète s'ils ont eu un
cancer s'ils prennent un traitement bien
sûr j'ai oublié de dire quand on
l'accueille bien sûr on lui met un
masque on lui fait des insectes et les
mains et en vue mais une paire de gants
aucun risque n'est pris pour le patient
et le personnel médical
le matériel est livré par des
industriels et laboratoires proches
après les questions place aux premiers
examens
prise de température tension calcul de
la fréquence respiratoire avant de
basculer dans le bureau du médecin
généraliste
les gens qui viennent ici peu pourrait
aller à l'hôpital donc c'est toujours ça
qui n'ira pas l'hôpital et qui
encombrent aura pas les urgences dans la
mesure où sont des gens qui sont
validées qui sont pas urgents en fait on
de noter piste aujourd'hui que les gens
qui ont une maladie chronique et qui qui
rentrent dans les critères de dépistage
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout venant c'est
à dire on peut pas dépister des gens qui
sont jeunes en bonne santé on va
déguster que ceux qui ont une maladie
chronique
seul le médecin prend la décision de
dépister ou non le passion pour moi med
diabétiques avec des problèmes
récurrents au coeur un test est
nécessaire il se plie donc aux consignes
des infirmières trois sont présentes du
lundi au vendredi au sein de ce centre
qu'ovide 19 ainsi que trois médecins
libéraux et une coordinatrice pour la
moitié des effectifs
il s'agit de volontariat moi je trouve
que c'est très très bien au moins ça
désengorge
l'hôpital et c'est très très bonne
initiative du maire ma mère elle comme
elle vit avec mon père donc voilà donc
elle est une personne à risque et les
cardiaques
elle a subi plusieurs opérations cette
année donc ça fait qu'on a un peu peur
pour elle aussi
donc voilà donc d'âge contre la ramener
de main pour qu'ils se fassent dépister
après le passage au centre les patients
sont suivis soit par téléconsultation
soit par un infirmier qui le rend visite
tous les deux jours pour l'heure une
trentaine de tests sont effectués par
semaine dans ce centre covit 19